i mean look at chris rock he repeats his  premise three times women can't go back  in lifestyle all the comedy greats have  this in common mark norman is one of  today's hottest comics  not that hot i mean hot like lit  shouty anyway he got this way like a lot  of great comics do by learning from the  greats of course i mean look at chris  rock he repeats his premise three times  women can't go back in lifestyle women  cannot go backwards in lifestyle women  cannot go backwards in lifestyle they  can't do it that's right they can't do  it i don't think the best woman can't  [ __ ] do it can't  [ __ ] do it they can't go back in  lifestyle women that's just him making  sure you get it you know exactly what  he's saying i've interviewed over 400  comics on hot breath podcast and i have  learned that you are never too young or  old to learn